the fight against corporate tax
avoidance is one of our top priorities
because we all pay the price when
certain companies abuse loopholes in the
system to avoid taxation billions of tax
jurors are lost that could be used for
public services like schools hospitals
security and to boost jobs and growth
Europeans end up paying higher taxes to
compensate for this lost revenue and the
majority of business that do pay their
fair share
lose out to dishonest competitors we
cannot close our eyes to this problem
any longer we've already done a lot this
past year to build a better tax system
in Europe today we'll present next set
of measures to combat tax avoidance many
of which follow on from the excellent
work done by the OECD over the past few
years this ambitious package will allow
coordinated EU action against what's
called base erosion and profit shifting
or bets we have a simple principle all
companies big and small must pay tax
where they make their profits how do we
do this we propose legally binding anti
avoidance measures to counteract some of
the most aggressive tax planning schemes
in the EU and beyond we encourage member
states to reinforce tax treaties to
prevent abuse in a single market that's
why we are recommending measures against
so-called tax treaty shopping we are
setting out ways to promote fair
taxation around the globe along with the
process to deal with countries that
don't play fair that don't play the game
last but not least our transparency
revolution continues this is not rocket
science multinationals need to provide
governments with a country-by-country
breakdown of their vital fine
information today we are taking a major
step towards creating a level playing
field for all businesses for fair and
effective taxation for all Europeans